hello kiddies and parents I won't keep
you long this is a short update on
what's going on here last time I spoke
to you all I mentioned that I was
getting mail from mothers and calls from
mothers they don't want to bring kids
back I'm proud to report that I have a
half a dozen letters from heroic mothers
who say yeah take them back I'm tired of
them so we're teaching online it's quiet
here on the campus but there's a lot of
activity I've taught one course online
another one tomorrow I was surprised at
how well it went this technology that
were using is pretty good the kids can
talk up you can have a discussion and
I've got a wagon big old class much
bigger than they run around here
but it seemed to me to work pretty well
and I'm encouraged by that
having said that don't make any mistake
we're not confused that this is not as
good to do our work as well as we do it
it needs to be done here there's this
great quotation that Professor Whalen
who wrote his doctoral thesis on John
Henry Newman who wrote the idea of a
university Newman says if you have to
give up the faculty or give up the
relationships between the students give
up the faculty then getting together and
talking and learning together he thought
that was the driving force I think that
too and of course we're coming up on the
time when senior dinners are going to
start and all that stuff so if we can
get back on the hopes for date which is
the week after Easter certainly can't be
before then because of the order of the
governor of Michigan if we can get back
then we'll have time for all that stuff
and so I want you to know I'm gonna be
working hard to try to make that happen
I will say that you won't have to come
back if you don't want to come back we
will keep teaching all our courses
online so we're thinking about all that
we don't have a plan about that yet I
told the faculty member the other day I
make decisions for a living but one of
the great rules that I've learned is
hard ones shouldn't be made until they
have to be made because you're likely to
know more when the time comes so we're
working hard at it
I do it if we can use this time to
improve your character and your
intellect I promise to do my best to do
the same god bless you and be safe in
this crisis